this is a virtual open house if you've
ever been home shopping and of course in
the middle of quarantine is never a
better time to go home shopping but you
can't go to the home so you gotta go to
a virtual open house this is a virtual
open house of a place called 15 6:15
Hollow Oak Lane a place I've been
looking at and you know I've decided to
be a lot less private about my life and
I just wanted to get your opinion on a
house that I was looking to purchase
proof of concept developed by North
Korea real estate in partnership with
optics dynamics labs all rights reserved
we're gonna go in and see what's up
[Music]
hello there my name is Peter and I'm one
of the your local north pre real estate
agents for the plot area nice to meet
you okay hi thank you for being part of
our alpha testing program we're excited
about our partnership with optics
dynamics labs still bring you the latest
in cutting-edge real estate technology
through nano drones photogrammetry
photogrametry and industry-leading
machine learning great well what does
that all mean well I'm glad you asked
for the first time ever we've made the
home buying process more convenient by
bringing the full open house experience
to the comforts of your personal digital
devices it's home buying revolutionize
for the 21st century
this sounds magical through a
combination of camera drones and
thousands of still images we can now
scan and recreate a fully explorable
three-dimensional snapshot of any home
for a seller that means no more dealing
with the inconvenience of multiple
showings for a buyer you can now browse
our entire portfolio while sitting on
your couch couch don't know what houses
we're excited to show you a perfect home
in your area it's a fresh listing from
one of our newer developments but before
we can get into all that fun stuff I'll
need to go over some basics of how this
all works don't worry it won't take long
I promise
moving your cursor around the screen
example the highlighted areas will
reveal different icons clicking on them
will turn left turn right move forward
moving your cursor over the information
bar will reveal additional options you
can click on this indicates that you're
currently a dog
now I think we're ready to get started
I highly suggest that you wear
headphones to get the full virtual open
house experience please keep all hands
and feet inside the ride and all time so
remember to have fun and do let us know
if there's anything we can do to improve
the experience because here at North
Korea real estate you are our highest
priority thank you
loading scan of 15 615 hollow Elk Lane
please be patient as this may take a few
minutes okay
[Music]
live chat make an offer detail the
entryway has a nice modern look with a
spacious vaulted ceiling there's also a
convenient guest bathroom located just
down the hall I think I've seen this
house before a million times in
different unity games but ok I always
wanted it in real life
overview oh my goodness
modest 385 beautiful three-bedroom
two-and-a-half-bath multilevel home
located new suburban development
features include uh I don't know what
that was
features include an up OK features
include an all brick fireplace hardwood
floors central air and nearby shopping
attractions great that's good stuff ok
um Wow
whoa yeah yeah I've seen this house in
house party this cozy living room
receives tons of natural light during
the day and the brick fireplace adds the
perfect touch of warmth for the cold
winter months beautiful this dining room
is the perfect entertaining space with
clear sight lines to the backyard and
living room as well as easy access to
the kitchen oh thanks thank you this is
great this is really something guys with
modern appliances and tons of space
you'll never have to worry about having
too many cooks in your kitchen
hahaha the giro Wow
the two-car garage has plenty of room
for storage and could be converted into
that perfect personal space you've
always wanted wow that is pretty good
what I'm sorry saw sa dump
detail Oh yep yep yeah okay nothing
wrong with that saw
righty-ho everything's good here okay
good good good good just gonna go back
you know just gonna go back Kizer
what I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
probably not probably problem probably
fine okay beautiful home
I gotta admit just flip dick and
gorgeous like flapjack and gorgeous if
you know what I mean wow this is
delightful
this guest bathroom has been recently
updated with new fixtures and plumbing
so you can rest assured that your guests
have the latest in modern convenience I
care about my guests
pooping
[Music]
hi-yah buddy
honey hey G all right thank you oh good
yeah you're right there buddy
face buddy what door just opened
was that a door upstairs was that an
upstairs e door
oh the front D door why did the front D
door open someone else see in this house
I can't get information about the stairs
they don't exist doc yeah that's a
little little weird okay whatever cool
no details here ooh definitely seen this
before
great let's try the master bedroom where
the magic happens how wink wink wink
wink wink wink nudge a massive walk-in
closet and ensuite bathroom make this
five hundred square foot master bedroom
your sanctuary for the house Alam Boesel
in everyday life I'm sorry is that a
hand that what would it mean look at it
buddy
hair hair that's what that is Hey
okay hair hair the on straw yung-shiu
bathroom it's beautiful
nothing weird here marble counters in
tiling at a sense of luxury that helps
you unwind and relax after a long day
well you are random event you are very
very correct okay oh that's nothing
weird in this room no oh don't look at
it
have I already looked at three of the
things that I wasn't supposed to look at
is that what that's suggesting for me to
look at the things that I don't want to
look at that's a thing ask you sum up
you ever heard demon whispering in your
ear before Bob I've never done it either
Oh something's wrong Oh God would you
have me look at silly Billy silly Billy
that's bizarre
well did you just eat rail oh haha are
you doing bud buddy buddy buddy
okay good no keys you have a good day
buddy okay currents can is the counter
to memory or recompiling data from an
earlier all right let's go back in time
goober got that
I'm beginning to think that this restore
point it's not a good restore point the
thing about this restore point is that
it's bad if I had to put in scientific
terms exactly what's wrong with this
restore point is that it's very bad this
is a bad restore point hmm interesting
there seems to be some blood a lot of
blood
unless it's Jam as dark is blood and
dark the blood here dark there it's
blood dark it's lark turn oh love the
house Oh No thank you no I'm gonna okay
you are you use arrow keys to repossess
I'm free missing scan data zero of four
well that's interesting please rescan
second floor you got it bud my this
drone I'm assuming this and this is scan
complete Oh
[Music]
this is something different it's inside
well inside what or inside whom whom
stays inside
what error inconsistent scan dimensions
what about the dimensions what about the
dimensions that we're all please rescan
master bedroom you got it baby
maybe if there's one thing welcome home
oh great thank you good to be home
excellent to be home in fact the best to
be home the dimensions are a little
weird here you were mentioning the
dimensions and now that you've mentioned
the dimensions I've kind of mentioned to
myself that the dimensions aren't quite
mentionable oh that's fun great good
okay time to mention look at my mentions
on Twitter's system play with unassigned
reference ok great ok good this drone is
boned by the way this drone drone boned
if I do say so myself drone very very
boned good thing I'm not there good
thing it's just a drone are we in the
back rooms is this the back rooms if a
house is I go backwards you know I think
it's trying to tell me I need to go
backwards back to the back room so
damaged oh my god thought that was Conan
O'Brien
hey cool thanks hey but wow this house
the square footage is so amazing the
value system locate player tag alright
oh well my spawn it character Oh
interesting
Oh fascinating oh good great
what okay okay am i back did I call
great good good stuff
okay so the thing at the top is not a
timer it said because a locator I'm not
sure if I need to oh it's an X Y Z
coordinate thing okay I get it didn't
think so
[ __ ] you thought you could sneak up on
me [ __ ]
the answer is [ __ ] you [ __ ]
element missing oh my oh my
I have nothing clever to say about all
this this is some messed up baloney hi
how you doing up there oh that's tab to
change cameras oh oh I'm in the ramen
dimension I'm in the noodle dimension
actually I was a clever even if I'm not
that was very clever
oh my D to make offer
I'll buy five hundred thousand not a
penny less I'll take it
man if okay
damn damn that was sick that was cool
that was rad Bao was really rad I like
that that was cool I really like that
really imaginative really taking it to
another level just the father created I
don't know the father is the it oh I get
it I get it I get it
[Applause]
that's me all right cool good so did I
get a never buying houses can be fine if
you don't go on the run buying houses is
such great that was cool
imagine sniffing ooh I like it crafty
interesting not too shabby so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to see more scary games that I
played in the past check him out in the
link in the description below if you
want to go check out this virtual open
house for yourself but watch out I'm
pretty competitive when it comes to
laying down for houses I don't know if
you'll be able to outbid me link will be
in the description as well thank you
guys
everybody so much for watching as always
I will see you in the next video
[Music]